you both are so good in this you know
this is a film that's executive produced
by reese witherspoon it's based on a
wildly popular book what is it like for
both of you leading this and being able
to experience that journey together
just such a privilege really and like
such an honor to be able to take on
these characters i think you know
because they're they're so loved by so
many people already um
so yeah i i don't know i i i kind of
still can't believe i got the chance to
play guy really it's insane i remember
this is the first project that my my
sisters called me about and to find out
if i was actually doing it and uh it's
the first thing they've ever cared about
that i've worked on it
for a while so i knew it was special and
i knew it had an impact on a lot of
people
so yeah sister's approval that's a big
deal big deal
i love that so much um what was the
first experience like meeting reese
witherspoon was it on set
it was yeah she came to visit and um and
it was really cool to see her take in
kai's like shaq because i remember the
first time i walked on that set i was
like this is
lifted from my imagination and you know
it's so exciting we've we've both been
fans of reese for a very long time so to
actually meet her and talk to her was
was really cool and you know i just i'm
such an admirer of hers in every way as
an actor but also as a producer you know
she really she wants to put women in you
know leadership roles behind the camera
and also you know complicated women in
front of camera too so it's just very
cool
so it's such a beautiful movie the
chemistry between you two was so
incredible but you are shooting in the
marshes there's water there's bugs i
just need to know what was it really
like on set exactly how do you imagine
it would be which is
perfect though it's exactly what the the
movie needed you couldn't do it on a
sound stage you couldn't film it you
know over an enclosed canopy you needed
to be out in nature to really get the
full experience
did you get used to the bugs what was
the most challenging aspect of kind of
being out there in the marshes
uh i'd say the mosquitoes probably
trying not to move in a
intense moment when you just got bit by
something yeah you had it out a few
times or something like me
really tested my acting abilities
it's like a super emotional scene and
you can hear them
yeah yeah yeah
that's the worst um so there's so many
themes explored in this film in the book
um there's themes of abandonment of
loneliness especially days with your
character is that something that you
could relate to as an actor
i think um i think feeling like an
outsider is a is a very human experience
and or feeling like you don't quite fit
in is very much a part of like growing
up and
and so yeah there's i think that's why
people relate to kyah so much is that
you know she
she's
a very human character you know she
she's very resilient and i think we are
very resilient as a species and you know
i read it during covid and a lot of
people did and i think we were at that
time very aware of um of the people in
our life that are important to us but
also of you know of a feeling of
isolation and of resilience of
overcoming a hardship so um so yeah i
think all of those aspects of kai are
really connected with
that's amazing uh taylor for you what is
it about this story and these characters
that you felt really connected to
uh i love the coming of age aspect the
first time i you know the first
this quarter of the book in it really
reminded me of some of my favorite um
movies growing up like stand by me and
uh and then as i continued on the
romance aspect funny enough was like um
it's not usually what i i'm obsessed
with but it drew me in and at the end i
didn't want
older tate and kai to let go of each
other i feel like they needed more time
i completely agree i was just so riveted
by this whole romance i was like i need
more
it was so fantastic both of you um daisy
i know you've been acting for a bit but
i feel like
audiences see this as like this huge
overnight success especially after
normal people came out and everybody
loved it so much
how would you describe the last few
years
i say they've been quite surreal
but i think they've been quite surreal
for all of us so so so i guess it's been
very tied up with like
lockdown on the pandemic and covered so
it's yeah it's been crazy really i mean
you know our normal people came out you
know during a time where we weren't
really able to leave our house so i had
no sort of reference for what actually
meant in my life you know this idea of
it being successful or being watched by
people so you know i think was when i
got cast in this film that i was like oh
yeah that's cool
that's different you know before i
wasn't always able to be seen for
projects like this so um i feel very
very grateful and and it's so lovely now
to be able to share the the experience
of it coming out into the world with the
people i made it with because you know
that's what it's about really is the
people you meet so you know i i really
i'm grateful that i'm able to share it
with everyone